let's talk about right now huh oh yeah
oh yeah so this uh last night we were
doing the members-only show and like
right in the middle we're like whoa
what's this story jack pasok tweets out
that the the prosecution withheld
evidence from the kyle written house
defense team
not true
it's actually not true what happened
they sent manipulated evidence to the
defense team it's even worse let me
explain how bad this is
if
the the prosecution they say they have a
drone footage actually we have this
article right here this is uh from
andrew branca day two defense files for
mistrial with prejudice you can see
image from the drone footage if the
prosecution presented the drone footage
in court the defense would have went
whoa whoa whoa we never we've never
received this evidence your honor let's
see so the prosecution instead gives
them grainy low-res video now uh i think
it was unrecated stream they played the
different videos side by side and if you
pulled it up on the tv and you were
given that the defense had no way of
knowing that this was not the video
they're given the video they play it
they say it's a video it's drone footage
makes sense to me
only when the defense played the video
in the in the in the jury instructions
did the did the state go
our version is much clearer
our version is much clearer now a lot of
people are like how's how dumb are they
why would they admit it they had no
choice if the prosecution was attempting
to pull a fast one on the defense to
make sure they had no way to analyze the
video to form a defense
they were that means they need the jury
to see their version of the evidence
which is clearer
when the defense played it they went oh
crap
we need the jury to only see our version
and the reason the defense is given the
low res version is so they can't
formulate a defense on time
so he had no choice but to say our
version is clear let's play that instead
now normally i'd say it was an accident
the argument is they texted the video to
the defense team which compressed it
that's insane to do now the defense
should have caught that but it's not
their fault they're told they're gonna
be given the footage and the video and
they believed it to be true and correct
but i'm not gonna give them the benefit
of that on this one they've committed
constitutional violations they've
ignored rulings from the judge
the judge says he's gonna hold this in
his back pocket until the verdict but he
very well may come back out and say
mistral with prejudice written house is
free to go wait can ask mike a question
because you're an attorney let's suppose
they they forgot right like there was a
video file and it's in a drawer and it's
like oops i forgot i have it now and i'm
a prosecutor in good faith and the
jury's already deliberating what am i
what can i do at that point as a
prosecutor who would be acting in good
faith
yeah that would so tech there's a they
call those brady violations brady is
information that could
go to guilt or innocence or
deal with
information and sentencing so in other
words it shows you as a maybe a better
person or more incent person than you
thought so if it's a good faith error on
something like that you could get a
mistrial with without prejudice okay and
retry it um that that would be the
remedy if you wanted it the defense i
don't know if they would depending on
how the case you're making a guess right
the defense lawyer would say
hey i think we're gonna win anyway and
not take it i have a correction yeah at
2 45 p.m the defense made a verbal
motion for a mistrial without prejudice
oh
wow very wow prosecution makes laundry
list of excuses over the state not
providing defense with high resolution
drone video judge warns prosecution he'd
warned them there would be a day of
reckoning over this drone video and then
says he's not going to make a decision
now inclined to see what the verdict is
going to be
on the 15th the defense filed a motion
for a mistrial with prejudice which
means they cannot bring the charges back
but it seems like the defense is so
upset over the cheating that they're
like just do a mistrial we will do this
over why would they want to do would
they do it over would they have the same
prosecutor yeah it would be the same
prosecutor but you know their whole case
now you have their witnesses on the
record so you they can't change their
story they can't be impeached
you yeah you have all this and then
there's that guy who
his criminal record has all come out now
maybe you didn't have that
the hit the dui against them being
dismissed maybe that comes in so there's
a lot of things that you're going to try
to bring in
in a do-over
and
all anybody can do is is guess right and
i think that so the defense
is squeamish now because usually a
longer deliberations means guilty oh
okay because people don't want to come
back quick from jury and convict
right because then it looks like you're
just a bad person like oh yeah you know
we heard the evidence 30 minutes guilty
boom you take longer but if it's not
guilty you come back right away now the
written house there's all the
speculation that there's a couple of
holdouts there are left-wing activists
and that it's going to be hung by two
left-wing activists nobody knows though
there's all a complete and total guess
as to do they need a majority to quit or
is it has to be unanimous either way it
has to be indians by the way oh so if
it's split it's a mystery it's a
mistrial and then and then they go back
and try it again
will chamberlain had some interesting
comments about this he said earlier that
quote pretty clear that rittenhouse
lawyers are getting jittery moving for a
mistrial without prejudice indicates a
serious worry that a guilty verdict is
coming back and that they want to get in
front of it so that could be a
possibility here as well i don't think
guilty so here's the way you would game
it out if you were you know if you're a
white born again you would say
okay if it already looks like the jury's
gonna be hung
right we don't know if it's going to be
hung because it was 10 to guilty and to
not guilty or if it was 10 not guilty to
hold outs they're going to hang it but
you're thinking you started going to
hang so then why would you even take a
choice that might be hanging because
it's going to be guilty or that they're
going to convince those two other jurors
to
to change their vote to being guilty so
you're thinking the odds would just say
let's just do a redo
and we have all this information now
that we can use but they still filed a
motion for mistrial with prejudice and a
verbal motion for mistrial are both
motions available to the judge well one
would supersede the judge can do
whatever he wants so the initial reason
they filed it the motion with prejudice
so there was that set of questions where
the prosecutor had said this is your
first time talking since august 25th
2020. now there's this is black letter
law that you cannot make a comment about
a person exercising his or her miranda
rights what does black letter law mean
oh it means it's not really up for
debate okay it just is if you take the
bar exam and you read that transcript
there's actually a right answer now the
prosecutor tried to say well i wasn't
commenting on his uh silence
i was just saying that because he was
able to watch the whole trial
he could key up his story and you
technically can make that argument but
you can't say this is the first time
you've talked you can say you can skip
that line and say hey isn't it true tim
that you've been sitting here for this
whole trial and you go yes well isn't it
true that you've watched everyone it's
testifying you say yes you go so isn't
it true then that you know exactly what
you have to say
in order to get the outcome you want you
can do that but no yeah right exactly
yeah you would say no i'm here to tell
the truth and there's all this back and
forth but the idea too and the
prosecutor is not very competent bingo
is not competent at all
when you're when you're cross-examining
you you just give a person a yes or no
answer you don't let him elaborate like
that he i you there's so many
just basic
tactical blunders that he made but that
would be the idea because then you would
say isn't it true that you could come up
with any story you want you would say no
i'm here to tell the truth and then it
doesn't matter because you're just
imposing your narrative on the witness
and cross-examination which is the way
it's supposed to be you're you don't get
to tell your narrative on
cross-examination the inquisitor gets to
and everything has to be a leading
question yes or no just keep it yes or
no isn't that true so fortunately bingo
is incompetent unethical
and i i tweeted out even you know
quoting michael mouse that to be
black-pilled is to think that binger's
gonna beat us right yeah like that these
are unstoppable foes yeah yeah they're
clearly they're evil
yeah but yeah but dude so the jury is
deliberating don't they know people
outside are screaming on megaphones of
course the jury should have been
sequestered that they're not sequestered
do you know that someone are you serious
and someone i know i didn't believe it
myself someone filmed the jury from
their bus pickup and the judge went well
we'll just make sure that doesn't happen
again when we deleted the footage and
it's like what yeah no and the jury's
got to be sweating bullets
right and there's no merrick garland's
not going to issue a memo saying that we
need to go after people who are trying
to tamper with the jury even though
that's how they get the mob for jury
tampering it's literally jury tamping
tampering happening here
and they're getting away with it so
they're definitely evil but they're also
dumb
and that's what so that if you're
looking at this from a big strategic
perspective right and that's what makes
them dangerous is
they don't have any morality
that much we know but they're dumb and
they haven't been through a crucible i
don't know if you saw adam schiff cry on
the view
over a couple of questions
and i'm thinking they they can't
understand any kind of immediate
scrutiny so they are weak can you
explain something else to me because
like i always try to steal man like if
something i don't understand like i'm
i'm thinking it's me why would how would
anyone as a prosecutor tell the jury and
and the audience that who hasn't taken a
beating at one point in their life that
seems like such a bizarre statement to
make like you said that yeah like what
am i missing
people make bad arguments okay yeah
is it what it looks like okay yeah i
want to address what you were saying you
know look zombies have no morality and
zombies are stupid but when you get a
whole lot of them you're in trouble at
least figuratively because no one's ever
actually been attacked by zombies but
you get the point no they out and that's
that was strategically is they outnumber
us
they're evil and they're dumb but that's
how you have to war game it out yeah is
but the problem with
you know conservatives or whatever the
case is the people who are supposed to
counteract it
is they
constantly refuse to accept that you're
dealing with the evil this isn't
they're not wrong they're not making
mistakes they're evil right they want to
like destroy people's lives i was yeah i
was just on uh rogan's show
and um i don't think it comes out today
i come back i wasn't tomorrow whatever
but i said chris cuomo was evil and joe
was like no man he's like he's not evil
like these guys are just doing
production they're not paying attention
and i said it's the banality of evil
chris cuomo pretended to be in
quarantine to trick people into thinking
he was locked down when he wasn't when
he was going to his private property and
got into a fight with some guy or verbal
altercation and i said it's evil to
willfully deceive the people yeah it's
lying it's called lying but but it's
it's more than lying we're talking about
people whose lives are being destroyed
by this and he's acting as an agent to
make sure they don't resist as their
businesses their homes their families
and everything everything's destroyed
i'm like it's evil it's tough because
this cell phone was built by slaves and
i i know that but i'm still i still
bought it and i still use it is that am
i evil
yeah
thank you michael the honest truth
that's not why
but isn't it still the banality of evil
that we knew that the foxconn labs were
so horrifying people were committing
mass suicide and we were like but we
accept this because we want it isn't
that the banality that we would just go
along with these horrifying systems and
the banality evil is more
the idea that evil doesn't come in the
form that you think it isn't charles
manson it was based on hera and it's
book where she would examine these
nazis and they're more like hey i just
want to like keep my job and i need to
get excellent that's what i choose yeah
but but hey look i just the phone i need
it for work
but cuomo is woefully evil right but now
banality viva would would imply that
he's just
like um hey i'm going to get vaccinated
for my job and i'm going to have a
vaccine and i'm going to show my
vaccination pass to people and i'm just
going to kind of cooperate because this
is what i have to do ian actually had i
think one of the best responses because
we were talking about whether or not the
npcs the zombie hordes are truly evil
and so i asked ian i was like ian our
zombie's evil and he immediately was
like uh well in d and d yes they are
chaotic evil but they're not they're
they don't have an alignment anymore
they made them neutral yeah they're not
neutral they don't have an alignment
whoa
what is happening ruin the funny topsy
turvy do your homework well the zombie
lord is evil i know that well the zombie
lord has sentience yes okay guys
i want to talk to you about evil
i want to talk to all of you about
the written house trial
and what we can see as reasonable mature
adults evil did you know that gage gross
kreutz in january 2021 had a drunk
driving offense
and the prosecutor said we'll make that
go bye-bye six days before the written
house trial let me show you here from
from new york post soul survivor has
criminal past they say gross kreutz 28
was in court just six days before
written as murder trial where he was a
star witness to have a recent drunk
driving charge dismissed on a
technicality
i wonder so weird yeah i mean we talked
about this a little bit when rogan came
on i kind of went off and talked about
all of his criminal charges the daily
mail called him a career criminal but
this wasn't his first dui this was his
second dui now i don't know anyone who
had a dui had a second one and was able
to get off of it when when the
consequences are so serious when when
you have a second dui i mean i we could
look up exactly the the ramifications of
it but the first dui in some states they
take away your car they take away your
license and you face a very long jail
term because of that a second one on a
long criminal record of domestic abuse
prowling trespass felony burglary two
counts of carrying firearms while
intoxicated on top of these two duis i
mean we're talking about someone who's
definitely not a upstanding citizen but
yet he's treated like some kind of
celebrity on good morning america which
he had his first interview on and i
think the nerds want to nerd out about
something we're getting into the
important stuff
i love this show yeah you are
fact-checked michael malus all right
something happened you were just talking
about how
these people are npcs they're zombies
and the question is are zombies evil as
of fifth edition dungeons and dragons
yes they are neutral evil all right they
don't tend towards law or chaos they're
kind of in the middle evil but they're
definitely evil okay so so for context
for context for people who don't
understand we're just making an allergy
to you have all of these people who will
vote democrat who will go along with
with lockdowns and mandates and
restrictions on civil liberties they'll
go along with the written house
prosecutor
presenting false evidence and they will
just say i don't care what happened i'm
on their side no matter what we call
them zombies and then the question was
but is that evil or is that just being a
zombie
ian told us last week that in d d
zombies are evil but michael contested
this and you've been fact check sir
zombies are evil i also think there's a
difference between npcs and zombies
though i think so too yeah
because zombies are actually actively
hunting npcs and this suggests that
they're neutral evil suggests that they
will betray the law at any moment for
their own self-serving purposes and
they'll also side with the law at any
moment for their own self-serving
zombies are mindless zombies don't have
an opinion on the law yeah you can i
mean you can get
you know what is evil does evil require
intent does it require outcome what if
you're in good nature and that's why i
don't use
um
and i really used to not use it but my
rhetoric has probably gotten a little
more fiery over the years i very rarely
say someone's evil almost never i used
to be the exact same way and i'd be very
philosophical like a lot of these people
are just not paying attention but we get
to the point where binger the the
prosecutor introduces fake evidence cgi
evidence
threat uh commits constitutional
violations defies the rulings the
problem is the judge let him get away
with it evil is rewarded well i don't
think that i agree with mike but i think
npcs aren't evil per se but the ones who
are running the show are the evil ones
right right the chris cuomo was evil
yeah yeah
don lemon's evil the lemmings who watch
cnn yeah they're just lemmings yeah they
would fall off a cliff they would
literally if chris cuomo told people to
do anything they would fall off a cliff
to their own detriment and if they were
born in idaho they'd be watching fox and
they'd be npcs and that's right right
exactly so they're just following
whatever they're told to do so they're
not they're not evil they're just
mindless
people who would go off a a cliff again
if they had
different but binger's evil
uh without question because the people
who are trying to lynch a 17 year old
are evil the pedophile who got shot
was yes was evil like pedophilia like i
put that on the evil list yeah and this
guy i mean
it it was the most atrocious i want to
not get into the specifics because it's
so atrocious
i don't think people want to hear what
he did to these children right he didn't
just it wasn't like he was watching
pornography he actually assaulted a
child more than a child i think that's
all different assault is not strong
enough we can't say what you know
atrocity yeah he committed atrocities
against children and abominations five
of them eleven counts ages nine to
eleven and there's no and there's no the
only reason he's allowed on the street
is because of our legal system which is
flawed if someone does that to a child
this person should never be allowed to
see the outside of a cell children i'm
kind of with you about i'm reticent to
call people good and evil because the
way especially the way d and d works
it's a scale from like yeah let me
reference the bible real quick
you have a rating from one to a hundred
evil being one good being a hundred and
you're somewhere on that scale 78 say
every act you do maybe it's an evil act
might drop that from a 78 to a 74. and
then you might do a good act to a tone
and then you might do something horrible
it kills someone and it drops to a five
and all of a sudden but that doesn't
count
it's not static yeah interesting it does
so you're you're not right you might be
able to say right now what you've done
we think you're evil that doesn't mean
you're not capable of good sure i
believe in god and redemption and i
think that i mean i believe in original
sense i think we're all we all have evil
in us so let me ask you this question
though ian if reza oslan of cnn eats
human brain is he a cannabis i don't oh
that's a good question
if you played tennis in your 20s but you
no longer play noah claire are you still
a tennis player well hold on but we're
talking about very serious actions i
understand people like i i would
actually argue if you played tennis
like you're a tennis player
but
cannibalism is something very specific
reza aslan of cnn on tv eight human
brain is it fair to get it though he it
was given to him by these this this
fringe sect of like hindu monks or
whatever but how could a human brain
have anything to do with cnn that makes
no sense cnn did a show
about religion
but hold on does anyone address the
question is raza azlan a cannibal even
though he's not eating humans well the
the idea and that goes to does your are
you defined by your worst moment right
and again that's why i don't like the to
use evil because if you're a lawyer
you've thought about this if you've
defended people charged with terrible
things
you think are you defined by your worst
moment and that's a question that
everybody has to wrestle with this
philosophical one so can you never not
there's even that joke that the guy said
he fornicated with the goat once and now
for the rest of the life he's a goat
fornicator
and my my belief generally speaking is
that there's a redemption period that
everybody's almost everything well if
you oh no hold on hold on i disagree
okay rosenbaum
10 years 20 years from now it's been 15
years
it had been 15 years since those actions
he committed
uh sorry is that the one who assault the
kids yes you don't come back from that
you don't come back but do you come back
from eating human yes he didn't kill the
human you didn't kill a person all right
what if you murder someone are you a
murderer yes yes forever yes in my
opinion if it's murder i don't mean like
drunk driving then why not a cannibal
like see this is this is it important
cannibalism is that bad in this context
but what i'm saying is what we're
basically saying is based on our
personal views of morality we're willing
to give someone redemption and not call
them a name by their worst moment if
someone murders someone they're always a
murderer alec baldwin is always a
murderer
is no longer a cannibal
i don't think eating human brains
like i said with stuff that happens with
kids is a little different
i i don't like to reduce people to their
to their lowest moment okay right that
generally speaking that's not how i view
humanity because my fundamental view is
that we're all whatever's in our hearts
and minds if that were published to the
world what would that look like right
and then you would say well that's the
evil thought that's different the
actions are different and there's a
whole sliding scale for this but my my
view generally speaking is
that you don't hold you don't define a
person by their worst moment with the
exception again with you know if you're
a serial child molester you know that's
a little bit different than a guy who
loaded up maybe something a video or
something that he shouldn't have there
could be a period of redemption after
that but in the families friendliest way
i want to make sure we stress that he
was beyond that rosenbaum was committing
atrocities against children worse
possibly the worst possible thing you
could imagine being done to a child that
they have to live with brother i would
also say don't define people by their
best moments yes because a lot of people
like alec baldwin's done a lot of great
work as an actor but if he does some
horrible crime i don't want to be like
well he's a good guy i think you let him
go that's why
bad moment is and how good the good
moment is right if someone's like a
firefighter and then he like you know
gets into a bar fight and beats somebody
up i'm willing to let that slide i don't
care about a bar fight anyway yeah
exactly yeah yeah i think there's a
sliding scale too because are we talking
about someone like henry kissinger
jeffrey epstein because they're in a def
different realm
of evil yeah comparatively to of course
you know low-level criminals petty
criminals arsonist there's a big
difference that's a good way if you
think of every action in your life is
weighting the scale of one to a hundred
if you've done a million things that
have given you a hundred and then you do
one thing that gives you a one it's
barely going to move the needle to 99
like henry kissinger is satan he is
absolutely evil he's great
do you like his ideas on limited war i
don't want to derail but i mean what
kissinger has done throughout his entire
career
uh propping up china and and the
communist state there uh indeed
industrializing the united states
bringing jobs over there putting the
current geopolitical situation setting
up saudi arabia with the petrol dollar i
mean the way that the world is right now
how broken it is can be directly
correlated to henry kissinger the man
advises the pope he advises presidents
he advises corporations he advised obama
obama's national security adviser said
he takes his daily orders from henry
kissinger and obama has a lot of
influence in the biden administration so
i i would say he's still in charge he
sat down with donald trump donald trump
was was licking his boots thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time